Have you ever had your
knitting fall off the machine?
Get your carriage stuck?
Or find that a stitch
patterns, just not working?
Even the most experienced machine
has one of those days now.
And then in this video we'll cover some
of the common things that can happen and
we'll talk about how to avoid them.
The links at the top of the video
will take you to other troubleshooting
tutorials available to
subscribers to Knit it Now.
Whether you're a new knitter or using a
new machine for the first time, one of the
first things you must know is how to
remove the carriage from your machine in
the middle of a row.
If for some reason the carriage
jams while knitting, don't force it.
Serious damage can be caused by a
knot in the yarn or mis-shaped stitch.
Follow your machine manual for the
procedure for removing your carriage or
opening your carriage to release a jam.
You're knitting along just fine, or maybe
you just change colors for a Stripe and
all the stitches drop off.
More than likely there's no yarn
in the feeder for some reason.
Maybe the yarn broke or you reached the
end of the yarn, replace the knitting in
the hooks of the needles or
ravel it out and try again.
Now to prevent this from happening, take
extra care to confirm that the yarn is in
the feeder correctly and watch for knots
and the end of the ball or cone of yarn.
Now, here's a tip.
If you're reaching the end of the cone or
ball, be sure that there's at least three
times the width of your knitting left, or
you'll run the risk of dropping some or
all of the stitches off
the machine unexpectedly.
If you find that stitches are dropped at
the beginning of a row, check the yarn,
take-up spring, make sure the
yarn is threaded correctly
and the Springs not caught up somewhere.
With some yarns you will need to take up
the Slack in the yarn at the beginning of
every row.
Also, be sure you're not taking the
carriage too far from the edge of the
knitting and causing this extra Slack.
If a single stitch drops off somewhere or
it's misformed, check for a bent or broken
needle.
You might notice that a stitch drops here
and there, or your carriage feels stiff
and it's difficult to push.
It's probably because there's
yarn tangled in the sinker wheels.
Remove your carriage from the needle
bed and check and remove any yarn that's
tangled on the wheels
or brushes underneath.
Another reason for the carriage being
difficult to push especially hard in one
direction is static electricity.
One method for removing static is to use a
dryer softener sheet, wipe down the needle
bed and carriage, the mast,
and even the cone of yarn.
If you find that an occasional stitch
tucks or doesn't knit properly, or maybe
all of the stitches are tucking, your
stitch tension is too low or tight for the
yarn.
Or it's feeding too tightly, so adjust
your tension and check that the yarn is
feeding smoothly.
You might notice a single
stitch tucking repeatedly.
This is caused by a bent
needle or a bent needle latch.
Replace the needle.
When stitches are tucking or they're not
formed correctly at the beginning of a
row, you're probably knitting too
fast at the end of the previous row.
Slow down your knitting.
When you knit too fast at the end of the
row, you pull those last few stitches
really tight.
There's no way they'll knit properly
on the next pass of the carriage.
Quite often, beginners will find loops
of yarn at the edge of their knitting, or
maybe the yarn gets tangled up in the
sinker wheels underneath the carriage.
The reason for this is generally that
the yarn take-up spring isn't operating
correctly.
Maybe the yarn isn't threaded correctly or
the carriage is taken too far and too fast
on the previous row.
So slow down your knitting.
Check the threading of the tensioner and
check to make sure that the spring is not
caught up and it's doing its job.
You're knitting along and you notice that
the knitting is starting to gather up in
one spot.
The stitches are caught
up on the sinker pins.
Well, this is caused by loose
or irregular yarn tension.
If you notice this quickly and maybe just
a single stitch is caught up, you can
often use your latch tool or crochet hook
and a reach down between the needle bed
and your knitting
pull up and release the stitch.
You can also pull the knitting away from
your machine and pop those threads off the
sinker pins.
The trick to both of these is to do it
without dropping stitches or catching more
strands of yarn on the sinker pins.
If your yarn is not strong enough for
machine knitting or it's old or weak or
brittle, it's going to break
constantly causing you gray hair.
Don't struggle if the yarn is fragile when
knitting, it's not going to hold up in a
garment.
If you're having trouble knitting,
here are a few things to check.
Is the yarn threaded correctly?
Check your tensioner, the yarn
take-up spring, and your carriage.
Is the yarn weight
appropriate for your machine?
Is it secure in the knitting carriage
check for bent or broken needles?
Is the tension that you're
using correct for the yarn?
Is there anything caught under the
carriage in the wheels or the brushes.
And are you knitting at an even pace?
The more comfortable you are with your
machine, the greater your success.
The entire Knit it Now learning library
is available 24 seven to subscribers.
Please subscribe today and let Knit it
Now help you be a better machine knitter.